[Applause]  [Music]  for millions of japanese people  springtime means one thing  baseball  but what a fan probably doesn't think  about what happens to all those broken  baseball bats  well one chopsticks manufacturer has an  answer  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  then  [Music]  foreign  wood from the iodomo tree was popular  for making fine wooden products and  professional baseball bats but because  of forestry mismanagement the species  was in trouble  [Music]  [Music]  instead of contributing to the problem  with that mr uratani put his plan into  motion  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  with the profits from these baseball  chopsticks mr uratani has joined  baseball leagues and teams to donate to  a group planting a new forest of aodamo  trees  [Music]  snake  [Applause]  you